cuáles crees que son mejores los países
grandes o los países pequeños cuáles
pensáis que tienen más éxito parecen
preguntas tontas pero amigos os
garantizo que no lo son
vivimos en un mundo donde cada vez hay
más países así que evidentemente cada
vez hay más países pequeños desde 1950
nuestro mundo ha pasado de tener unos 60
países a casi 200 hoy en día así que
amigos creo que esto nos obliga a
plantearnos unas cuantas preguntas y
esto es algo bueno o algo malo son los
países pequeños viables vamos a verlo en
este vídeo pero antes un apunte cuando
hablemos de países pequeños nos vamos a
referir a países con una población de
menos de 10 millones de habitantes y
también incluiremos a hong kong y macao
porque aunque formalmente sean parte de
china bueno tienen sus propias leyes sus
propios tribunales sus propias aduanas
etcétera etcétera
hong kong tiene su propia moneda su
propia política de inmigración y también
policía aduanas y tribunales propios
vamos que en el día a día funciona casi
como un país independiente pero dicho
esto vayamos a la cuestión clave a qué
está pasando con los países pequeños y
ojo porque este es un tema muy
importante en la política internacional
todos lo sabemos una buena parte de los
conflictos políticos tienen mucho que
ver precisamente con esto
con el deseo de muchos territorios de
declararse independientes y constituirse
en nuevos países
la fuerza de los pequeños
amigos no cabe duda los países pequeños
no suelen estar entre los grandes
protagonistas de la actualidad
internacional no se les tiene muy en
cuenta los grandes conflictos no
participan en las grandes decisiones y
la verdad su actualidad política suele
ser una gran desconocida y al fin y al
cabo es algo normal todos conocemos al
presidente de eeuu al de francia o al de
rusia pero a quién le importa a quién
manda en países como irlanda dinamarca o
taiwán si es verdad en visual político
solemos hablar de ellos pero realmente
no es algo tan frecuente
pero amigos esperanza un momento porque
a pesar de todo esto lo cierto es que en
los últimos 30 años si algo ha
caracterizado a los países pequeños ha
sido hacer las cosas bastante pero que
bastante mejor que los países grandes de
hecho cada vez que se publica un ranking
sobre cuáles son los países más ricos
los más innovadores son los más
competitivos los más felices o los más
seguros los países pequeños ocupan casi
siempre la mayoría de las primeras
posiciones y si entonces es cuando nos
damos cuenta de que existen y nos
preguntamos cómo diantres lo hacen
fijaos si cogemos por ejemplo el ranking
de los países más ricos del mundo esto
es el de los países con un pib per
cápita mayor nos encontramos con que
entre los 10 países más ricos del mundo
9 repito 9 son países pequeños
y por cierto de estos nueve países ni
más ni menos que ocho tienen menos de
seis millones de habitantes es decir que
son bastante más pequeños que bogotá o
incluso que el área metropolitana de
madrid
pero bien si en vez de tomar los diez
primeros venga ampliamos un poquito la
selección y escogemos los 25 primeros
pues en ese caso vemos como la cosa
cambia algo pero no mucho de los 25
países más ricos del mundo atentos 17
son países pequeños y si además tenemos
en cuenta la diferencia de precios esto
es si tomamos el pib per cápita en
paridad de poder de compra
entonces ya los datos son de escándalo
en ese caso los 14 territorios más ricos
del mundo son todos países pequeños
y ojo amigos porque hablamos de países
muy pero que muy diferentes
tienen mucha densidad de población como
singapur otros muy pocas como finlandia
algunos tienen muchísimos recursos
naturales como qatar y otros
prácticamente ninguno como irlanda
hay países más agrícolas y otros más
financieros grandes en territorio y
otros muy pequeñitos es decir que la
variedad es enorme pero todos tienen una
característica común son estados
formados por pocos habitantes
hablamos de países como islandia nueva
zelanda luxemburgo noruega irlanda
dinamarca singapur austria-suiza o
finlandia por ejemplo pues bien
precisamente en 2014 y en 2015 dos
estudios publicados por la unidad de
investigación del credit suisse
colaboraron esta situación
estos estudios encontraron que los
países pequeños tienden a ser más ricos
más igualitarios y más avanzados
socialmente de hecho de media invierten
bastante más en cosas como la educación
o la sanidad
y eso no es todo por si no fuese
suficiente los países pequeños suelen
tener las cuentas más ordenadas tienen
menos deuda menos déficit y también
menos impuestos a pesar de lograr
mejores resultados sociales bueno es que
incluso si nos fijamos en sus mercados
financieros en las bolsas por ejemplo
vemos como en las últimas décadas los
mercados de los países más pequeños han
tenido mejores resultados atentos
e
así que amigos insisto con una pregunta
que estoy convencido muchos os estáis
haciendo que está pasando cómo diantres
lo consiguen bien veámoslo
las claves del éxito
porque los países pequeños tienden a
funcionar mejor que los más grandes no
se supone que los países grandes tienen
mercados más grandes más oportunidades
de negocios y encima más capacidad para
aprovechar economías de escala qué es lo
que está fallando y no lo siento el
cliché de los paraísos fiscales no vale
ni finlandia ni austria ni dinamarca ni
por supuesto nueva zelanda por ejemplo
pueden ser considerados bajo ningún
concepto paraísos fiscales
entonces cuál es la explicación bien
como solemos decir aquí en visual
político nunca suele existir una única
causa pero sí podemos decir que la
prosperidad de estos países procede en
gran medida de su propia debilidad tal
cual como lo escuchan estos países
pequeños están más expuestos al comercio
internacional no solo para vender sino
también muy importante para comprar los
productos que necesitan es evidente que
un país pequeño no puede producir de
todo y luego también están más expuestos
a la competencia ya los vaivenes de los
mercados financieros internacionales así
que amigos esto les obliga a ser más
prudentes con las cuentas a cuidar su
competitividad y por supuesto no pueden
permitirse el lujo de aplicar políticas
proteccionistas de hecho 21
repito 21 de los 25 países más
globalizados esto es que más abiertos
están a la circulación de mercancías
personas y capitales son países pequeños
por su parte si queremos ver como estos
países se preocupan por la
competitividad de su economía y de sus
empresas tan solo tenemos que echar un
vistazo por ejemplo al índice de doing
business del banco mundial que como
sabéis clasifica los países por su
facilidad para hacer negocios pues bien
atentos al último twin business de 2018
que el banco mundial publicó el 31 de
octubre de 2017 el ranking doing
business del banco mundial también está
dominado por los países pequeños nueva
zelanda singapur dinamarca y hong kong
ocupan cuatro de las cinco primeras
plazas entre los 25 países del mundo
donde más fácil resulta hacer negocios
16 son países pequeños de estos 16 15
tienen menos habitantes que el área
metropolitana de madrid
y aún existe otro motivo de peso más
veréis los países pequeños suelen tener
mucha menos burocracia primero claro
porque no necesitan tantas estructuras
políticas o al menos es más difícil
justificar las segundo porque los
ciudadanos suelen ser más conscientes
del coste que suponen y tercero porque
simplemente no se lo pueden permitir
el resultado de todo ello amigos es que
los países pequeños suelen ser más
flexibles más competitivos y menos
burocráticos claro que puede que alguno
de vosotros esté pensando pero enrique
no será que estos pequeños países son
más ricos precisamente porque se han
creado sobre las zonas los territorios
más ricos pues lo cierto es que no
tenemos por ejemplo el caso de irlanda o
singapur que hace apenas unas décadas
eran países bastante pobres y hoy son
dos de los países más ricos del mundo y
también tenemos otro buen ejemplo la
antigua república checoslovaca
la prueba de la separación
si nos vamos a tierras de fonseca que
seguramente dentro de no mucho tiempo
nos cuente esta historia con todo lujo
de detalles pero hoy tan solo un par de
apuntes mira en 1993 checoslovaquia
decidió dividirse en dos países más
pequeños de la república checa y
eslovaquia
por aquel entonces los dos países
estaban sufriendo los efectos de la
caída de la unión soviética y estaban
experimentando una dura transición pero
la parte checa era mucho más rica que la
parte eslovaca
de hecho en eslovaquia la renta per
cápita era apenas un 65% de la checa la
tasa de desempleo era casi 5 veces más
alta y encima la región eslovaca era muy
dependiente del dinero que llegaba en
forma de solidaridad interregional desde
la parte más rica del país o sea de
chequia
pues bien desde que se separaron en 1993
a los dos países no les ha ido nada mal
consiguieron realizar con éxito la
transición desde un modelo comunista a
un nuevo modelo capitalista y los dos
han crecido bastante más por ejemplo que
alemania ahora bien de los dos países el
que más progresos ha logrado ha sido
precisamente eslovaquia si así es poder
organizarse por sí mismo y al mismo
tiempo tener que competir favoreció
sobre todo a la parte más pobre fijaos
como desde entonces se ha producido una
clara convergencia entre los dos países
atentos a gráficos
pero de todo esto ya os digo que estoy
seguro fonseca nos hablará con todo lujo
de detalles pero amigos por mi parte un
último apunte antes de terminar
la nueva configuración del mundo
seamos claros la globalización ha hecho
que ser un país grande ya no sea una
ventaja y no sólo eso lo cierto es que
en el mundo que estamos construyendo
aspectos como la competitividad la
apertura y la capacidad de adaptación
son cada vez más relevantes y de momento
amigos en ese ámbito los países pequeños
parecen más eficientes los países
pequeños e incluso las ciudades si
habéis escuchado bien en nuestro mundo
las grandes ciudades se han convertido
en los motores más importantes del
crecimiento económico
londres y su city hong kong singapur
macao las ciudades cada vez juegan un
papel más importante en nuestro mundo la
economía de yakarta crece el doble que
la economía de indonesia el pib de nueva
york- es dos veces el de suecia y los
países con más porcentaje de población
viviendo en las ciudades tienden a ser
más ricos así que viendo todo esto me
hago una pregunta a tenor de los datos
no deberíamos apostar por estados más
pequeños descentralizados o incluso por
dar cierta independencia a las ciudades
ahí lo dejo
por supuesto nada de esto está reñido
con desarrollar organizaciones
supranacionales para hacer frente a
muchos de los riesgos a los que nos
enfrentamos desde el terrorismo hasta el
cuidado del medio ambiente
pero ahora turno para ti que crees que
es mejor un mundo con muchos y pequeños
países que colaboren y compitan entre sí
o un mundo con pocos y grandes países
déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios
y también en esta encuesta si te ha
resultado interesante el vídeo dale a
like y no olvides suscribirte a visual
politics si aún no lo has hecho un
saludo y hasta la próxima